لقد أتيت إلى هنا لأول مرة كمتدربة في
عام 1978. واو ،
نعم ، للرئيس كارتر لمنصب الرئيس
كارتر ، لكنه كان عالمًا للرجل كان
عالمًا كاملًا للرجل ، كانت
أنيتا دن واحدة من أوائل النساء في
السياسة الرئاسية اللائي غيرن ذلك
وهبطت في النهاية في الدائرة الداخلية
من حملتين فائزتين
وإدارتين رئيسيتين أوباما والآن الرئيس بايدن
كموظف مبتدئ في عام 1984
في حملة جون جلين ، لقد حددت معايير
عالية لنفسها ،
اتخذت قرارًا
بأنني في المرة القادمة التي أردت فيها العمل في
حملة رئاسية
كنت سأذهب  أن أكون على الطاولة ، لذا
لم أعمل في الحملات حتى
وصلت إلى نقطة حيث كان
مقعدي دون أن أحصل على هذا المقعد من خلال العمل
كمساعد في الكونغرس ثم
مستشارًا سياسيًا لعدد لا يحصى من
الحملات الديمقراطية للكونغرس
رغم أنه كان من الصعب العثور على عمل خلال ذلك.
في انتخابات عام 1996
عندما كانت حاملاً ، هل صحيح
أن المرشحات فقط هن اللواتي يوظفنك حقًا ،
فسأقول إذا نظرت إلى من وظفتني في
ذلك العام ، نعم هذا مستقيل
شخص حقيقي سيتصل بي ويقول إن لدي
هذا المرشح في المدينة أريد أن
أحضره لمقابلتك وسأكون
أنزل الدرج في
أكثر نفسي حاملًا ويمكنني فقط
مشاهدة وجه المرشح مثل
وبعد ذلك  لم تحصل على الوظيفة
ولن يتم تعييني بالطبع ، لا
أريد أن يعرف الناس أنني أمي
تحدثت بصراحة عن أنني لن أحضر
أو لا يمكنني أن أكون في تلك المكالمة لأن ذل
كان  محفوفة بالمخاطر في ذلك الوقت ،
لكنني شعرت أنه مهم إذا كان لديك
نساء
كبيرات يتحدثن بصراحة عن
أطفالهن والوقت
الذي سيخصصونه لأطفالهم
ومعايير
علاقاتهم مثل أنني أغادر
المكتب كل يوم  في هذا الوقت من
أجل الالتقاط في الحضانة ، فإنه يمنح
النساء الأخريات الإذن ، لقد
كان متعمدًا تمامًا ،
نعم الآن العديد من النساء
المحاطات بهن في البيت الأبيض في بايدن
لديهن أطفال صغار معروفة
بامتلاكها سياسة الباب المفتوح
أنا  لا يؤمن الإرشاد
على الرغم من ذلك  أنا سعيد بإرشاد أي
شخص يريد أن يمشي من باب منزلي
والحصول على بعض النصائح ،
أنا مؤمن بشدة بالرعاية ،
ما هو الاختلاف
الكبير في إرشاد دانا ،
ويسعدني أن أقدم لك النصيحة.
يسعدني أن أكون لوحة الصوت الخاصة بك ، ويسعدني أن
أكون جدار حديدي عندما لا تسير الأمور على ما
يرام
ولكن الرعاية هي دور نشط للغاية في
مهنة شخص
ما ، ليس فقط سأقدم لك
النصيحة ولكني سأقوم بذلك  الترويج لك بنشاط
كان رعاتها من الرجال نظرًا لوجود عدد
قليل جدًا من النساء ،
هذه رسالة توصية كتبها
قبل 45 عامًا تقريبًا من قبل
رئيس موظفي البيت الأبيض كارتر ، هاميلتون جوردان
دان ، يُنسب إليه الفضل على نطاق واسع
في قلب حملة بايدن خلال
الانتخابات التمهيدية لعام 2020
بعد  الخسائر الفادحة في ولاية آيوا وهامبشاير الجديدة
في نهاية اليوم يتعلق الأمر بتحديد
الأولويات وعدم الخوف من اتخاذ
قرارات
الأشخاص في السياسة الذين يخشون
اتخاذ القرارات
يفقدون مديري الحملة
ويفقدون العملاء.
تقول إنها انضمت إلى هذه
الإدارة مؤقتًا فقط للمساعدة
في أزمة الطمع
وسرعان ما تركت طموحي الأول
هو أن
أكون مذيعة رياضية حقًا ، نعم ربما لم تكن
قد عشت
هذا الحلم ، فأنا شخصية تنافسية للغاية
دانا ،
لذلك انتهى بي المطاف في السياسة لكنها  بخير